ouais là choisir un sport d'affaires
pauvres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cela
la dernière
st
m
[Musique]
françoise et la misère fois qu'il
revient sur sa chaîne c'était dans
l'émission de nagui jamais si la
fonction publique at il des républicains
c'est un format première c'était il ya
presque 13 ans incroyable dans les
sous-sols de la française des jeux au
moins quatre on va s'inspirer pas à les
arrêter si forte et voilà treize ans
plus tard voilà c'est cool dimon de jeu
qui voter il ya un badaud sur le plateau
avec marc estia césar compter du art et
mixé 14
vous pouvez même cas ni la cause parce
que les six n'ont donc j'ai eu bruyckere
donc il prend vizorek com merci
oui ça va comme on sonne à eau
o o
[Musique]
le voit plus qu'un de ces termes
pourquoi
florine floride
chez moi
g
moi j'adore c'est des moments avec
thierry dans la loge branche le maquille
via voilà vous pouvez y alla bout si
pour la déconne on rigole de vie chère
ou si on y habite chaque est là bien sûr
et puis voilà ces documents sont super
privilégiés qui les a beaucoup servi
quand elle sait quoi je vais manger ce
moment là moi parce que c'est le dernier
je vais branches et j'ai apprécié ma
dernière fonction de tv avec quoi on
verra après c'est sûr c'est pas de la
dernière fois que je suis sur le
téléthon toute ma life et que tu
commences à ce que je n'ai donc sur le
tueur et sa maman toi audrey rapproche
de l'humain passe et tu bosses pas
d'heure
c'est une idée allait réclamer vengeance
avec son ex mari
attention vous êtes présent on est prêt
[Musique]
landry a
tous
[Musique]
il faut qu'elle prévoit de mettre salle
à ces festivals ce disque je puisse la
voir
c'était le préparer
[Musique]
et parra o
yara
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi
[Musique]
l'avancé de conte et privés gèrent vous
pourrez dervier été racontée sans enfant
un petit enfant à nos arrières petits
enfants
on s'entend en parlant non ma grand-mère
dernière 2-1 cet été j en fait non
nous on est vrai dans tous les cas merci
des classes et des super plaisir qu'ils
tombent
j'espère comme si un autre code du
travail
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
la merci pour le silence aussi redoubler
les applaudissements 3 2
[Applaudissements]
et même une tour l'agresseur blessé de
médicaments il faut arrêter les clés
sont
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
c'est
nous fait du pognon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le gars est survenu à 4 fois que je les
emmerde et je communie recommande à ces
débordements accès moment il sera en
oublie un peu moins mais quoi qu'il
arrive je ne vous oublierai jamais merci
à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà c'est fini on va pas me renvoie
recolle sur le quai d'une gare
je dis seulement au jour
et c'est grâce à l'amour
x
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ou demain ces mamans ou
t'aimais je t'aime
[Musique]
l'état
mais
c'est fini
[Musique]
oh
abbas dire au revoir
kelly là
j'te
si seulement mon
des gages à l'ailé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
aujourd'hui
là elle même
peut-être après demain
je te
redoutent
car cette nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une scène
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
par le dit
[Musique]
palais
j'irai
on
[Musique]
par me dit
et de même cisco
il
ça vaut
soit jamais à me reste toujours sincère
ce que tu as voulu
pas plus que tu allais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus